in just a few moments khalediko lost
everything
the three-story building where his
family used to live collapsed
the tragedy in lebanon's second largest
city tripoli has scarred his
six-year-old son mustafa
his younger sister jumana died under the
rubble
[Music]
in our country the government doesn't
care about us we knew the building
needed repair but we couldn't afford to
move
thousands of families are living in
danger because of the poor state of
buildings
temporary fixes to reinforce the
foundations are not permanent solutions
four families live in this run-down
building
look at these stairs they are about to
collapse it will cost us three thousand
dollars for repairs we don't have four
dollars in our pockets
local authorities estimate up to 10 000
housing units are at risk of collapse
they say there is only so much they can
do without the central government
addressing the economic collapse that's
forced much of the population into
poverty
there's a ticking bomb in tripoli we the
municipality are doing our job by
warning people to evacuate but the
solution is the responsibility of the
government
any solution requires money and the
lebanese state is nearly bankrupt but
even before the current economic crisis
tripoli was neglected
the united nations says this city more
than any other in lebanon is in need of
social housing there has been no
development or investment for decades
many of the buildings are old and
haven't been maintained
some were damaged during the civil war
that ended in 1990 and the political
violence in the ensuing years
others were built illegally with poor
quality materials
how can you blame those who can't afford
construction materials or restoration
costs they were already poor and they
have become poorer with the collapse of
the local currency
many here know their buildings aren't
safe but they have nowhere else to go
all they can do is wait for the next
tragedy
al jazeera tripoli northern lebanon